i really want to start with a sincere
thank you i laughed my ass off last
night and i just want to thank you um it
was great
um so i i'm so curious what do you think
fans of jackass would be surprised to
learn about the actual making of a
jackass movie
the smell
is horrendous it's horrendous very
consistent bad smells of dave's pooping
constantly just everything there's so
much weird odors all the time i'm not
even joking
oh
i i see it on screen i i there's a lot
of [ __ ] flying around it is
you know
i'm real
uh jeff seems to be willing to film
literally anything and put you guys
through the ringer is there a safe word
that you are given to actually tell jeff
this i i really need to be left alone
it's always been oklahoma he started it
but it doesn't do any good
jeff's specialty is making people do
things that they're not comfortable
doing and once he learns that and if you
do a safety word that just means you're
gonna have to do it even more yeah i'm
terrified of ice cream
it's like if someone's really upset and
you tell them to relax it has exact
opposite effect yeah
well the other thing is like i i'm
curious what it's like when you're
actually filming because you
like when you're home is your blood
pressure high just because you know that
at any moment jeff could walk through
the door and [ __ ] with you or is it sort
of like you know when you're home you
might be safe there's no safe place
anymore yeah when something starts to
seem weird and you're even if you're in
the safety of your own home you just you
start to think wait a second yeah what's
really going on yeah booze and
cheeseburgers got my blood pressure high
he blames it all on the booze and
cheeseburgers not jeff
for all four of you um what is the most
scared you've actually been
uh what was the most scared you've been
when you were standing on the set of
this movie
knoxville's bull scene
yeah yeah it looked like he died
yeah i thought he died that was tough
tough day yeah really tough that was
very sweet we were supposed to film like
three more bits that day that was the
first thing in the morning that was it
we're done we stopped filming after that
for like a couple weeks i think
yeah it was right before christmas yeah
right before christmas
merry christmas but it looks red yeah
turned out well oh he's okay for the
most part
i i was uh jaw on ground um eric
anything you want to uh add yeah those
are those really good one the ball one
for me as well like my heart almost
stopped like just to see it like if if
when you see the film you know how many
times he flipped around it didn't look
real in a sense so it was
very overwhelming even when he was
getting shot at the cannon i was like i
hope it doesn't backfire
like
you know there is so much that you're
just kind of
how does it go
so obviously spike jones is involved in
this uh production um but i noticed that
no one really [ __ ] with spike is there
an unwritten rule on set that like he
cannot be messed with no there's not we
kick him in the nuts every now and then
yeah he gets nut shocks
he's not afraid either he'll take and
he'll do anything he usually instigates
it yeah he likes it he'll he'll kick you
first you're like all right well
and then he'll say harder harder and you
you feel a little bad because he's so
he's a big time dude just i don't know
but you got to do it
there's no there's no safe person or
safe place when you're on a set of
jackass ever since the beginning like if
you're there if you've signed a release
it's on you don't know what's gonna
happen
uh needless to say as a fan of jackass i
was i'm so happy you did it but it's
been 10 years do you actually think like
this could be the beginning of more or
do you like maybe jackass the next
generation like or do you think this is
kind of
this might be it i feel like we're
exactly halfway in our progression which
means we've got what 22 more years 22
more years
and we'll always be involved it'll
always be the og crew and last man
standing kind of thing
we could be doing jackass for another 22
years for another 30 years who knows
we keep writing ideas and we keep being
able to if we can't move our bodies
we'll write ideas that involve us not
moving our bodies like whatever i'll be
right there behind eric the whole way
the day that our the tv show the first
episode aired it was the day that
eric was born yeah conceived
oh born
that's crazy yeah
i had no idea that's crazy listen i
gotta rap i'm just gonna say and i
really mean it thank you for everything
thank you um you guys have a fantastic
day pleasure thank you thank you
you